Beginn einer Reise in ein
Kriegsgebiet die kommissionspräsidentin
von derlin kommt es geht nach
Kiev es ist eine Reise gegen das
Vergessen vonlein fürchtet der Krieg in
der Ukraine Gerät in den Hintergrund
wegen der Krisen im Nahen
[Musik]
Osten Brüssel geh an die polnische
Grenze dann mit dem Nachtzug nach kieev
38 Stunden wird der Blitzbesuch
dauern der Zweifel an einem Sieg der
Ukraine im Westen wächst die
Unterstützung bekommt erste Resse
vonlein fährt nach Kiev um Mut zu
machen wir drehen ein Portra über sie
deswegen wenn wir sie ein bisschen
begleiten dürfte ich ihn eineil wir das
dramaturgisch eine persönliche fr
stellen kontrolliert persönliche Fragen
sind
sensibel sechste Reise ist dass die
Ukraine wenn ich glaube ich richtig
von mit welchen Gefühlen fahren Sie die
Ukraine jetzt gerade auch wenn sie die
Welt tragen
seh das ist immer ein Gefühl der
Anspannung wenn man in die Ukraine reist
aber auch gemischt mit der tiefen
Überzeugung fest an der Seite der
Ukraine zu stehen und ih diese Botschaft
wieder zu bringen mit im Gepäck fliegen
die großen Gesten den ukrainischen
Präsidenten haben sie als Held gefeiert
kein Gipfel auf dem er nicht der
Ehrengast war mehr als alle anderen hat
von derlin die Hoffnung geschürt dass
die Ukraine einmal zur EU gehört nun
fährt sie nach Kiev um dieses
Versprechen zu
erneuern ihnen deutlich zu sagen wir
wollen euch in der Europäischen Union
haben aber dafür muss das Land sich
weiterentwickeln und ihr müsst diese
Reform machen das ist immer die
Herausforderung für mich und natürlich
ganz entscheidend auch gerade in diesen
Zeiten ihn Mut machen und in
Vergewisserung
gehen wenn man nicht so genau hinschaut
dann sieht man die Schrecken nicht
gleich
aftivk im Osten der Ukraine das neue
Schlachtfeld das neue bachmut dort
finden die schlimmsten Kämpfe mit der
russischen Armee statt mit vielen
Toten die Welt schaut in die andere
Richtung die Kämpfe im Gazastreifen
bündeln die Aufmerksamkeit der
Nahostkonflikt hilft Putin der hofft
dass der West nicht zwei Konflikte
bewältigen
kann es geht ja uns allen so dass wir
manchmal erschöpft und überfordert und
überwältigt sind von der Masse der
Herausforderungen der Krise aber wenn
man dann ein Moment
weiterdenkt dann ist auch wieder klar
die Ukraine kämpft einen unendlich
wichtigen Kampf für uns alle und es ist
in Europas Interesse dass die Ukraine
frei souverän und eine Demokratie ist
und dann lohnt sich der Einsatz und jede
Anstrengung Ankunft in Polen in der Nähe
der ukrainischen
Grenze die Anspannung in der Delegation
steigt wir dürfen keine Gesichter keine
Abzeichen keine kenn
zeigen wahrscheinlich hat die Kommission
auf noch offenen diplomatischen Kanälen
die Reise Moskau angekündigt doch
Vorsicht
bleibt der Bahnhof ist
abgesperrt von derlin hat eine lange
Woche hinter sich Westbalkan London nun
Kiev sie wirkt müde noch ein paar Sätze
für die internationale Presse Sätze die
sie so oft gesagt hat die aber jetzt
nicht mehr selbstverständlich
sind die wichtigste Botschaft ist wir
stehen an der Seite der Ukraine solange
es nötig
ist Ankunft Kiev die Stadt ist von
Angriffen zur Zeit
verschon vonlin setzt ihr
begrüßungslächeln auf das Amt der
kommissionspräsidentin ist ihr zur
zweiten Haut geworden für jeden ein
nettes Wort dabei schon fokussiert auf
den
Hauptdarsteller Frist du nicht fragt
selensk nein sagt sie die zwei sind sich
vertraut beide haben die gleiche
historische Mission die Ukraine dicht an
die EU heranzuführen dafür braucht es
Ausdauer geehrt werden die Mitarbeiter
der ukrainischen Bahn sie sind Helden im
Land denn die Bahn vor immer sie blieb
die Lebenslinie der Ukraine eine
Geschichte über
Widerstandsfähigkeit der sie gerne
zuhört die ukrainischen eisenbahne haben
dazu beigetragen 4 Millionen Menschen
aus den Kampfgebieten zu
evakuieren vonlein hat sich mal als die
beharliche beschrieben und selenski als
den entschlossenen nun gibt es Urkunden
für
Widerstandsfähigkeit für Heldentum ein
perfekter
Termin esuch
beginnt Gespräch mit selenski es geht um
die militärische und wirtschaftliche
Hilfe Treffen mit Premierminister vor
Sandsäcken mit dem
Parlamentspräsidenten überall herrscht
die Sorge dass der Westen in seiner
Hilfe schwächelt in den Beifall für die
kommissionspräsidentin schwingt viel
Erwartung mit aber vor allem andere
entscheiden ob sie erfüllt werden ob und
wie die Ukraine überlebt
[Musik]
Kiev ist nach wie vor eine schöne Stadt
der letzte größere Raketenangriff mit
Toten war Ende
August für die Sehenswürdigkeiten ist
Katharina
zuständig die Reiseleiterin will den
Touristen den klanz der Hauptstadt
zeigen damit Sie wissen warum die
Ukraine
kämpft einil der ist einfach kriegsmüde
aber wir haben natürlich immer noch
einen großen Widerstandswillen wir
wollen unser Land beschützen und
befreien ich kenne unzäige Menschen die
jeden Tag für die Armee Geld und Sachen
Spenden die freiwillig kämpfen
wollen Army
[Musik]
volte die Spuren des Krieges haben sich
bis nach Kiev auf dem michaelplatz
durchgefressen die russischen Soldaten
marschierten Richtung Hauptstadt nur die
Bahn brachte die bedrohten Menschen aus
den Kriegsgebieten
raus die Ukraine eroberte Gebiete
zurück die zerstörten Panzer von dort
aufgereiht doch der Krieg hat sich
festgefahren beiden Seiten Ukraine und
Russland fehlt die militärische Kraft
zum entscheidenden
Schlag Katharina glaubt den nooch an
einen Sieg wie viel in der Ukraine will
sie nicht mehr über Niederlagen
nachdenken ich bin mir sicher wir werden
die besetzten Gebiete in der Ostukraine
befreien ich glaube fest daran meine
Familie lebt in den besetzten Gebieten
meine Freunde leben da und sie warten
darauf dass die Ukraine zurückkommt nur
5% der Menschen dort unterstützen
Russland diese fühlen sich nun stark und
glauben sie sein jemand vorher waren sie
das nicht aber 95% der Bevölkerung dort
warten auf die Befreiung durch die
ukrainische
Armee auf die Befreiung warten während
die Hauptstadt wie eine Festung wirkt
das Regierungsviertel begrüßt die vielen
Staatschefs mit Sandsäcken nicht mit
ehrengarten die Militäroffensive der
Ukraine ist nicht so gut gelaufen wie
viele im Westen erhofft haben
sie ktenwinnen wenn sie nur genügend
Waffen bekmen selenski wird sich nicht
beschweren er wirbt für mehr Hilfe er
sieht müde aus verständlich nach mehr
als 600 Tagen im
Krieg die Menschen sind müde sie sind
erschöpft das ist eine ganz normale
menschliche Reaktion unabhängig in
welcher Lebenslage Sie sich befinden
daran ist auch nichts
auszusetzen nicht in einer Sackgasse
fest das ist mir wichtig deutlich zu
machen ich glaube wir haben aber kein
Recht zu verzweifeln aufzugeben denn wo
führen solche Gedanken hin was ist die
Alternative sollten wir ein Drittel
unseres Landes einfach aufgeben das wäre
doch nur der Anfang die Russen hören nie
auf die kommissionspräsidentin befeht
keine Armeen sie hat keine Waffen was
sie aber fürel hat eine icht eine
Hoffnung dass Europa vielleicht bald mit
ihm über einen eubeitritt spricht weil
er sein Land so gut
reformiert ich möchte Ihnen sagen wie
beeindruckt wir von ihren politischen
Reformen sind die sie sogar während
eines Krieges durchgeführt haben wir
dürfen niemals vergessen sie kämpfen ums
Überleben und zur selben Zeit
reformieren sie ihr Land sie haben viel
erreicht sie haben das Justizsystem
reformiert den Einfluss der Oligarchen
beschnitten die geldwäche bekämpft und
noch so viel
mehr vonlein war hier um Mut zu machen
einem Präsidenten der müde ist wie das
ganze
[Musik]
Land sie ist schon fast ihr halbes Leben
in der Politik so viele Posten so viele
Krisen aber der ukrainekrieg ist mit
nichts zu vergleichen nach 10 Stunden in
der Hauptstadt kieev ist sie überzeugt
es geht ums Ganze
unsere Art zu leben steht auf dem
Spiel ich hätte nie gedacht dass ich in
meinem Leben einmal so sehr um den
Bestand der Demokratie kämpfen muss und
die Ukraine hat meine tiefe Bewunderung
und mein Respekt ich habe Menschen
erlebt die alles im wahsten Sinne des
Wortes dafür geben dass die Demokratie
obsiegt und die Freiheit und das berührt
mich zutiefst und umso mehr sp kommt es
auch an die Ukraine zu unterstützen es
sind unserem Interesse im europäischen
Interesse aber es im größeren Sinne auch
entscheidend für die Frage siegt die
Demokratie und ist sie auf die Dauer
stärker und
überlebensfähiger zurück in Brüssel hier
wird über das Schicksal der Ukraine
entschieden drei Tage später empfieltt
vonlin den europäischen Regierungschefs
Beitrittsgespräche mit der Ukraine
aufzunehmen das ist erstmal nicht viel
aber es klingt nach großer
Hoffnung